(mellow hip-hop)
- Oh that's superb, it's
called snakefruit in english,
sala in Thai.
What a wonderful fruit.
Good morning, I hope you're
having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens, I'm in
Chanthaburi, Thailand,
and this is day three of our eastern
provinces of Thailand food tour.
Today we are driving
from Chanthaburi to Trat,
and there are, we're gonna stop at two
legendary restaurants, and
that's the plan for the day,
so I'm gonna share all
of the delicious food
with you in this video right now.
And we've got a whole bag for the road.
(mellow hip-hop)
There's this one phrase
in Thai, (speaks Thai)
and that directly translates to,
if you haven't eaten this dish,
you haven't arrived to this destination.
And every province in Thailand,
almost every city has a
couple of these dishes.
We are about to eat this
dish, and it was just about
a 15-minute drive from
the center of Chanthaburi.
This is a place, it's in the countryside,
it's gonna be good.
(speaks Thai)
(mellow hip-hop)
Here it is, the dish is
called kuay teow moo liang,
and this is, if you ask
anyone from Chanthaburi,
a dish that you cannot miss
when you visit Chanthaburi,
again the dish that you
haven't arrived to Chantaburi
until you've tried, this is the dish.
You can choose your noodles,
and then there's some pork in it,
and then she also has
a beef version as well.
I think it's all about the broth.
In that broth simmering
you can see whole chunks of pineapple,
and there's both chicken
and pork in there,
and so definitely the
first thing you have to do
is just taste that broth.
Mmm, yeah it does have that kind of like,
fruity, acidic touch from the pineapple,
but like with all good bowls of noodles,
it's time to season.
I'm gonna go in first
for some chili vinegar.
Oh this is some thick
and hearty chili vinegar.
Oh that looks fantastic,
and then of course,
you gotta go in for the chili flakes.
Stir this up a little bit,
and I went with senbei,
which is this type of rice
noodle, the medium-sized.
There's also a little bit
of vegetables in here,
some water morning glory,
and then some other herb.
Oh, that chili vinegar, that's good stuff.
Overall, the entire dish is
a little on the sweet side.
The broth is kinda sweet, but
balanced with that vinegar
and the chili flakes, it's good.
I'd like to try the beef version next.
And also some meatballs,
same noodles, same broth,
but this is (speaks Thai)
which is like braised beef.
We gotta go in for that broth,
and I'm go in for some
of those herbs as well.
Oh that pineapple sweetness,
and this chili vinegar is
the condiment of choice.
This is where it's at.
And mix that around, add a little bit
of those little chili
flakes, mix this guy up.
Okay, and on this bite
I gotta go for some,
a little bit of everything,
especially with that beef.
(mellow hip-hop)
Oh, that's still really hot.
Okay, how 'bout a meatball.
Oh, that has a pretty nice texture,
and you can taste the
black pepper in that.
Meatballs like that have
really started to grow on me.
(mellow hip-hop)
For me, it's okay, not amazing.
It's a little on the sweet side,
but it's definitely a dish you have to eat
when you come to Chanthaburi,
and the location, they're really friendly.
The location here is fantastic,
the atmosphere is great.
From here, we are driving towards Trat,
and the next restaurant is the one
I'm most looking forward to today.
We're gonna have a rice and curry feast
of local Trat dishes.
It's about a 30-minute drive to get there,
we're on our way now.
(mellow hip-hop)
(speaks Thai)
That was about a 30-minute
drive to get to this restaurant,
and this is one of the most
legendary (speaks Thai)
restaurants, which is rice
and curry restaurants.
We just crossed over the border
from Chanthaburi to Trat,
so we're about 20 kilometers
outside of Trat town right now,
but we're in the province,
and we're here before 11 a.m.
They only have a small
selection, but the good new is,
they still have some
awesome dishes to try,
and I ordered everything
they had that looked good.
(speaks Thai)
And by the way, this restaurant is called
Khao Gaeng San Toong.
I'll begin with this dish right here,
which is called (speaks Thai) and
this is a dish that I've never had before.
It's some type of fish, stir-fried with,
I think it's cucumber, there
are some herbs in there,
there's chilis, this looks fantastic.
It looks awesome.
(moaning happily)
Yeah, it's a very firm fish,
almost like, like a tuna,
and then the cucumber
and the type of melon,
it's really soft and sort
of melts in your mouth.
You've got, I believe
that's holy basil in there,
which has a little bit of a peppery,
almost tingly sensation to your tongue.
And then it has a, has a little bit
of a sweet/spicy balance to it.
Next dish is (speaks Thai),
this is some type of
little snails or shellfish,
I think some type of, looks
like little blood cockels,
and then that's pineapple, but you can see
all the chilis folded in there as well.
Oh, oh that's awesome.
Something I love about the
food in this region of Thailand
is how they really mix
the savory with the sweet,
but for the sweet how they
often use lots of fruit.
Of all the dishes though,
the dish I'm most excited that they had,
that I had to order immediately
was the (speaks Thai).
Now, kwang is a, it's a type of deer,
and it's stir-fried with naw sabparod,
which is the top of the pineapple,
you know that part with the
kind of spikes that come off
that you pull off the top of a pineapple
before you cut open a pineapple.
That is what it's stir-fried with,
and I think it's the bottom pieces of that
where they slice it up finely.
I believe the official name
for it is pineapple crown,
it's the top of the pineapple.
Oh that is the dish.
Absolutely sensational.
You do, I mean if you think about it,
you can actually taste the pineapple.
I mean it has more of a subtle flavor,
it has a texture that's
similar in a crunch
that's similar to a bamboo shoot.
It has this really, like,
satisfying crunch in your mouth.
Okay, that's the dish.
I think I better order
another plate before they
run out of it.
Oh that's good, that's outstanding.
Next dish is (speaks Thai),
and (speaks Thai) is king mackerel,
but then they're made into
lukchin which are meatballs,
or fish balls, and it looks
like a nice green curry sauce.
That one's a little more
on the sweeter side.
It does have kind of a
more green curry property,
so I think they are using
green chilis in that,
and it has a nice refreshing
citrus-y taste to it.
Maybe coming from those kaffir lime leaves
as well as the basil in
there, the sweet basil.
The fish meatballs
themselves are very spongy.
They have an extreme bounce to them.
And finally, just 'cause they had it,
we got a, this is a mackerel.
It's kind of a candied, it's
definitely gonna be sweet.
I knew it was gonna be sweet.
It's okay, it's not my favorite.
It almost has like, a sweet and salty,
syrupy kind of taste to it.
Put on a few chilis, and
this dish is also a stunner.
(mellow hip-hop)
(speaks Thai)
And this is one of those dishes
that I absolutely had to order
another plate for dessert.
There's nothing more
exciting in front of me
than this plate of food right now.
That's just spectacular.
That is my favorite dessert.
Wow, what a dish.
You can really taste the
black pepper in there, too.
Oh that's a pure happiness dish.
(mellow hip-hop)
- Micah?
- Was that Micah?
Micah, did you scratch my nose?
I just noticed I have a
little scratch on my nose.
Okay.
That was a spectacular meal,
and even though they didn't have that many
choices of dishes to order,
all of them are good,
specifically the deer
with the pineapple crown.
And just, every time I say crown
I gotta go like this, pineapple crown.
That's the dish you have to order,
that's the dish you have to eat,
and it will be impossible
to stop at one plate.
You'll have to eat two
back-to-back plates,
one plate for dessert.
Oh, my mouth is just rejoicing.
That's one of those plates of food
where your mouth is rejoicing
after you finish it.
We probably have just
about 15 or 20 minutes
before we arrive to the
center of Trat town.
Whoa.
And a little snakefruit to finish it off.
If you could smell the car in here,
the entire car smells like snakefruit.
Kind of like that, that
fermented fruity taste.
Alright. And we're off.
(mellow hip-hop)
Welcome to Trat, and I can already feel
the relaxation setting in.
That was just about a 15-minute drive
from the restaurant to get
here, and we're staying
at a place that's called
Baan Rim Nam Resort.
I'll have the information
in the description box,
but Trat is very well-known,
especially as being a jump-off point
for many of the different islands.
So, a lot of people just kind
of pass through this town,
go jump on a ferry or speedboat,
and head directly to the island.
But, we have two full days here,
have some very cool things planned
that I'm gonna share with
you in this video series.
We'll be doing a full food
tour of Trat the town,
and then also have a trip
planned to a village to cook some
local food that will all be
coming up in this video series.
But for now, today we're
just gonna hang out.
So I'm gonna end today's video right now,
what a day it's been.
What a spectacular meal.
I still have the flavor of that deer
and those pineapple crowns
lingering on my tastebuds.
Oh, that was delicious.
Okay, thank you so much
for watching this video,
and stay tuned for the next video.
Remember to click
subscribe and also turn on
your bell notifications
so that you get notified
of the next video that I publish.
Thanks again for watching,
and I will see you
on the next video.